guys uh I came in here I sat down and uh
there's a Guess Who game that is on the
table which Mark has asked me not to uh
reveal my suspicions as to to why it's
on the table until we started the
podcast yeah so I'm not going to say
anything I would love you to explain to
the group your curiosity got the better
of it hell it needed to know I mean I
have always loved guess who it's a
wonderful I've been amazing it guess who
really yeah I wonder why I don't know
you just crowd workor black what black
gu the black guy so Miles and I we were
at a bar this weekend in Williamsburg in
Williamsburg with fodo and we hanging
out after the New York City marathon
yeah and uh I saw a game of guess who
sitting there and I immediately picked
it up and I was like we're going to play
you would go to those types of bars yeah
right yeah yeah I bet they have changa
oh dude it was this is the whitest bar
that's ever no no here's the
thing just I just have to preface this
Alan and I make fun of you for going to
These Bars because we're older than you
yeah when we were your age we were going
to [__] [__] [__] Barcade or
whatever that [__] was like no no like
we were going to themed bars because you
thought that that was cool what was what
was the Crocodile on when you got the
free
pizza Alligator Bar try trying to pick
up girls on ski ball you're like oh you
want how you get a free pizza if you buy
just get in Williamsburg they were
trying to get people to go to bars so
every bar gave you free like elos it it
was like the [__] I was bad I it was
like what we ate as a kids they it's not
New York Pizza it's like frozen pizza
but they're giving it out and you're
hammered you're like [__] it I'll tell
you what a dwe I am I went to a bar just
to play pingpong once didn't drink a
drop that that's that's fine I a going
lie that's F you didn't go to a bar you
went to a ping gym and it was in
Williamsburg the first time I ever went
to Williamsburg oh I feel like I know
what you're talking about and I I
remember walk this is when hipsters ran
it and I didn't know what a hipster was
but I I swear I got there and I told my
friend I go I want to burn this entire
place to the ground I don't know what's
happening until you started playing ping
pong the Ping pong's fire ping pong is
My Sanctuary anyway so we go to this
caucasian bar yeah and uh we're having a
great time I after we play and I'll
explain the way that we played I
immediately bought guess who this was a
whole rig R to get this I bought the old
guess who though and it's only white
people on the old guess who no there's
one black there's one and he's like a
lightskinn there's a brown isn't there I
thought there was a couple nonwhites
it's like a handful okay and by less
than a handful this is a little diverse
I'm not into this no no no no you're
about to me and then I literally went to
the store today bought this and I had to
call the the toy shop and was like hey
do you guys have Guess Who and they're
like yes and I was like do you have the
new one and he was like what do you mean
I was like the Tropical Skittles
literally I'm trying to explain to a
black guy on the phone like the one
that's more diverse and he's like yes
yeah yeah Hasbro really messed that up
we got the you do you guys have Guess
Who and I had to explain to him like
with the blacks um but we finally got it
Dad so the way that we played so this
guess who has a has a Litany of
different people
um a whole menagerie of different
ethnicities and races and religions I
this [__] is sticky Mark I was playing
bro mark this shit's sticky I was
playing a little I told you I got one
game in before you hold on don't it how
How does it go see you got to hold it
like this so just flat out and then they
all come this last one wouldn't come out
bro this Carmen hey hey kmen to look
like Miss
Pat car son this guess who is phenomenal
so the way we play normally with guess
who you're supposed to oh my anyone ever
played guess who if you're not from
America maybe you don't have it guess
who you basically play by trying to
guess characteristics like oh is your
person wearing a hat do they have a
mustache can I go can I think that's too
easy our version of guess who you're not
allowed to say any physical descriptors
no physical descriptors are allowed it
can only be social cultural uh you pick
somebody relig religious phenomena do
you pick the person you Dr you and AOS
pick you and aosh are on a team AOS you
guys pick a person okay don't tell us we
just move this wherever you tell me and
we're going to pick a person you just
point to whoever you want to pick you
know point to one of these or one of
these one of these let go uh H hold on
one second cassetta I'm fixing this
audio you don't have to worry about a
single [__] thing okay got it
cassetta you don't worry yourself for
one second while I fix this [__]
audio I'm not fix okay okay I don't even
know what that is can go up too what do
you think oh you know no what do you
think what about that one right there
yeah right there one over okay all right
ready or or hurt okay and we start okay
all right we got ours we got ours you
get five guesses and then at the end of
five guesses you have to guess who the
person is okay okay is your person fa's
Dad no our person is not F's Dad okay
you guys go okay um I got one uh was
your
person uh liable to get punched by a
black guy on the subway during
Co no no no they were safe they they
were safe okay okay you go okay okay so
then what do we oh can I go can I go uh
does your person have a
[__] I thought we can't use oh yeah you
can't use physical distri right if you
go racial stereotypes well that is a
racial
stereotyp okay go go you said no we have
to like turn some women yeah no no no no
no we just got to get rid of
Lily yeah flip the ones down don't think
it is exactly and the men so we know
that it's not that person we know it's
not that person she's clitless for sure
and the men you can ask a question Mia
might not have one either uh Laura's
looking pretty
clitless uh okay okay okay you go you
guys go go ahead Alex um would your
person wear a pink [__] hat what what
does that mean like a oh wait hold on
hold on yeah what does that mean like
the ones that they go to DC marching cuz
like the [__] walk what yeah he might he
might oh oh
[__] you really can't use pronouns in
this no it's a pronoun game thank for
that okay okay you go aash you go okay
all right um does your person know how
to pour a latte with like design art
like a flower
or a heart oh honestly maybe that's a
solid maybe but not like minorities
right yeah definitely not definitely not
Carmen you said your person does or does
not have a [__] no no clits they said no
[__] so no clits we should get rid of
good luck oh yeah cuz they do have a
[__] right so oh yeah I think we we need
do this over all of them
shouldn't none of them should if so we
should get rid of the men and the Muslim
women that's what we're saying exactly
yeah so okay we got we got to rule out
some of these guys you guys go um did uh
just does your guy despite being 13% of
the population commit 51% of
the just I'm it it narrows it down Alex
no it narrows it down it helps I'm
saying it helps say it's so much fun
being a cop like being a detective is so
much fun and I get it now well G to
knock these guys off okay um would your
person try to get a black guy killed if
he was watching birds in Central
Park
good no no no I don't not that's really
good that's that's really good okay we
got to rule these guys out that's really
good okay you guys
go do you want one you got it all right
um
does would your guy go into like a like
a high school and shoot and shoot kids
that's tough I don't think so I I think
not but it's tough definitely okay no
definitely no definitely close that one
out okay all
right um I think
yeah uh
uh is your person Pro black lives matter
except where his dick
goes honestly yes
Jordan no oh that was a good guess dude
no wa who's Jordan which one is that the
black gu with the blonde hair or skat
shop black oh fck skate shop
black okay wait do we have one more
guest yeah you we have one more okay we
have one more um they got one of these
okay uh is your
guys uh one of his favorite foods like a
piece of nonre that got rubbed under an
Indian guy's
armpit yeah I think I think so no hell
yeah no it's no it's no but it is though
it's it's one of his favorite foods just
covered in flies no it's not it's not
cuz I know where he's going no can we
just keep on going it got I don't know
if we're Clos okay all right um I think
it's that he tried to throw us off okay
okay uh did your
person
um buy the rights to medication and then
increase the price to as
no okay definitely not okay there you go
okay okay do we have the same person
dude we might have the same person
there's way I think their person this
okay go go you guys
go okay um if your guy does your person
travel on flying carpets or on top of
trains no no no what no not at all okay
all right but their person travels on
flying carpets because they they think
we have the same person God damn
it [__] I mean we have that okay let's
just narrow down one more okay just pick
the [__] camel jockey and let's get
on with it what are we
doing which one of these [__] Aladdin
idiots is it dude uh Leo no I think we
already no put ours down I think it's
the other one I I have two I okay go you
guys guess who okay I think I mean we
thought you guys had [__] Sam no they
is your guy Leo
no no okay can I do one more yeah okay
um we must have accidentally put theirs
down already does your
guys uh wife come to work on a Monday
with black
eyes if the
Patriots don't cover the spread I don't
think so definitely not okay no Daniel
okay okay oh I knew it was Daniel too
soon said that I knew exactly who it was
all right guys we're going to take a
break real quick because I got to tell
you about exter this is I don't care
what wallet you have you need one of
these if you don't have a wallet and
you're looking you get yourself an extra
if you have some [__] designer
product Christian Dior whatever wallet
you still need one of these and I'm
going to tell you all the reasons why
first of all quick card access take a
look at that ba there you go all your
cards pull out whatever one you need
that's just convenient second it don't
take up much space you put it in your
side pocket and you're living third and
this is the most important thing it has
two key tracker features first of all
that means it is trackable worldwide if
you lose your wallet or somebody steals
it you could just call that [__] up it
works on uh voice activation with Siri
uh Alexa Google home all that [__] and
most importantly again this is what I'm
telling you even if you got a nice
wallet you need one of these this has
RFID protection which means if you're
traveling if you're a tourist and you're
in one of these cities we're afraid
you're going to get pickpocketed or
scammed or people are just going to skim
your information like that Boop like
that Boop this protect protects you
against debt so no matter what wallet
you have get yourself an extra keep
yourself safe it is convenient it is the
best wallet you can get and you can get
a discount because we're flagrant and we
always hook you up go to shop.
extra.com flagrant and get 25% off
sitewide with the code flagrant again
that is
shop. ekek
s.com flagrant get 25% off and now let's
get back to this exclusive patreon clip
if you want to watch the full episode
come hang out with the boys you can do
that at
patreon.com flagrant or patreon.com
flagrant 2 come join the [__] Army
it's the best army to be a part of okay
[__]
um
okay I'm trying to think did did your
guy not get into a prestigious
University uh because of his ethnicity
and scoring too high on an SAT that was
quite possible it's quite possible that
yes we're back
on we're [__] back on dude I know
exactly who you got does your guy make
uh you just asked you just asked we go
too
excited it's it's one of we just got to
find we know the we know all the
stereotypes it's some [__] carpet
monkey we just got to figure out which
one we got to figure out which one
dude oh God so we knocked down all these
but we're kind of it's not I think we
accidentally knocked it down did we
choose this one I I got one in the TU
did we choose this one yeah that's him
they said no you said no to Leo yeah
yeah it's not Leo and we asked I thought
that was tar for a second I thought that
was your friend
T um are you telling me yours isn't Mike
no who's M oh no it's not
Mike I mean I guess yeah Sam it is Sam
dude it's [__] Sam Bro and what did
you guys think our okay does your guy
make educational video essays on crime
and money and also practices tech
window no no no no is yours Gabe no [__]
dude come on MAR it's Mike how did you
guys not get that you got it like five
times in a row yeah yeah you really
kicked the [__] out of the guessing but
I he would get punched on the subway no
he wouldn't only Asians Asians dude Mike
is Asian Mike is not asan what are you
talking about that
guy no look at his eyes his name is Mike
how many asan
mik yeah is he Asian I think he's white
dude he's fully an Asian man the Hipster
version come on they got an Asian with
you're not punching Mike on the subway
straight up I'm punching Mike on can we
get no you're not not he would know you
know I I dead ass Mike is not Chinese
enough for you to punch I know this for
a fact come on I know you would look at
him and be unsure one more one more one
more one more come on okay let's go one
more one more you choose you
choose um okay I I I I got it all right
do you guys got it yeah do you want that
one yeah oh oh come on Al immediately
gives it away he can't hand he can't
handle himself all right we got it go
ahead go ahead okay okay ready
mhm okay
um
okay
um uh Logan
Paul person is not L Paul okay well is
that David what is that David well I
think there's a
couple no it's none of them okay um
okay
um okay would Logan Paul make a video
about any of your characters killing
themselves in a
forest no um I might say
l okay okay who do we want to rule out
here
um okay does what a phenomenal
game what an absolutely phenomenal game
okay um diversity does make things
better it does handled correctly if
handled correctly hand correctly you got
to let us tell our story we got to play
this publicly this has to be played at a
quiet coffee shop does your person think
all lives
matter
oh see you Daniel that was a really good
got a lot of people does yours have a
pet oh that's good
that's Alex Alex keep it real Al
possibly but nah no like a dog or you
mean like dog or like a just
anything I'll be honest yeah no okay I
really we're getting rid of a lot of
people
here see you later see you later see you
later
see I think that's about it about this
guy you don't think that's no definitely
not
um would your person uh be happy if
their uh kid came out as trans would
they be accepting if their kid was
trans that's tricky it that's tricky
that I can't tell you I I genuinely
can't tell you it's a great question but
honestly I I don't know damn yeah it's
tough I don't know It's Tricky and if we
when we when you find out who it is
you'll see why it's tough
okay respectfully yeah yeah back in the
day if this person had nice feet would
you smash respectfully of
course
no doesn't really narrow down
yeah probably not dude no oh wait if
they had nice feet you you would I might
there we
go I
might okay all right we want to play
that game all right would Alex have sex
with your person uh yes take out the
black women
done okay did your person sing the
popular
R&B uh song The Thong
Song bro are you talking about
Carmen you [__] [__] no we don't
have kmen but that's a great guess okay
okay just just making sure okay go go go
go
goes does your person work at
Zoomies
no I don't know what the [__] Zoomies
is okay all right ready
M uh did your
person engage in homosexual Behavior to
join a fraternity in college certainly
not certainly
not okay
I think you can get rid of this guy too
yeah yeah um did your person develop
Facebook
no no not at all okay
okay okay this is okay we got to have a
good one
um it um would your person get an
abortion for
fun no you got out yeah none of them
look like me
all right I think we got
it okay we got to get one guess and just
really knock him off the board here
um is your is your person allowed to
read
yeah
damn okay ready okay who do you have Ben
no what who's Ben oh the guy that made
Facebook no we don't have I would [__]
Ben what the hell [__] I didn't
think the [__] [__] come on there's a
couple guys here who get it but not B
we're we're [__] no you said Al
wouldn't [__] no I said would I would I
would damn it oh it's one of these white
women y but they all would get an
abortion for fun oh it's true it's yeah
you kind of misled Us Al [__] is a
little misleading I don't think Al would
marry her but he would [__]
her that's fair
yeah fair or there we got to see with
the background like it's only a head
shot might be abortion fun this is
probably not a yeah okay okay okay okay
all right um would your
person
um be a Fox News
anchor I think in a
specific specific coverage [__] is going
on dude specific cover specific
coverage it's like a segment
yeah but but no not not like at the desk
like hello welcome to San Diego I am so
lost does your person Crouch to smoke
cigarettes
no it's
good you so lost bring them all
back CU he's in no I'm like lost guess
what you pick a one it's a woman right
we know that we know it's a woman okay
um
okay
um oh I mean this is this is really
tough
um does your
person's crotch smell like a hamster
cage that's a good one that's a good one
uh I think stereotypically possibly yeah
but I personally take it down I take it
like getting a getting a Vibe on her I
doubt it I think I think it's smelly CR
but that was for research purposes does
your person uh have arm hair and it's a
little
gross no actually probably none I would
guess really no I don't think so
okay yeah definitely
not
yeah
H
not would your person definitely not
this yeah would your person's brother
confront dove in Amsterdam uh-huh
yeah it could be either one it's got to
be Farah no dude Lily
yeah I take that [__]
down okay who do you think we have bro
I'm so lost dude I'm like did you have
Mia no kman dude Cisco wait you had
Cisco yeah [__] you would [__] Cisco he
would wait you would [__] Cisco listen a
can't be choosing I would [__] Cisco if
she had nice feet damn you're
Progressive bro just just Palm it yeah
yeah why not dude she's pretty that
threw me up so wait you guys were
playing this publicly yeah any good ones
while you guys were playing I trying to
think there's a there's a black guy that
kept switching behind Mark to get like
it was really packed bar and he kept
going behind and Mark would do this
thing where he goes uh does your guy and
then he'd look behind him just to see
where he was and be like does your guy
uh have what's food what's this
situation with food stamps or something
along well also I was like I think foda
had a black dude and I was like oh would
your guy drink at this bar and he was
like nope and then all a sudden he looks
at he goes actually maybe I was like
okay got him